[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 23 février
hier c'était le 21 février 2014
le 22 février n'a jamais existé pour moi
je viens de passer la ligne du
changement de date
au milieu du pacifique quelque part
entre tahiti et la nouvelle-zélande
je suis en train de faire le tour du
monde et comme je vais plein ouest dans
le sens inverse de phileas fogg une
journée disparaît c'est quand même
curieux une journée qui n'existe pas
j'en suis plus à une surprise près parce
qu'il s'en passe des choses inattendues
quand on fait un tour du monde
surtout quand on le fait seul pourtant
rien ne me poussez cette aventure là
tout va bien
j'ai une vie riche riche d'amis riches
d'une famille aimante
riche d'un pays qui est passionnant en
intelligence collective auprès de
grandes entreprises riches déjà de
voyage en sac à dos mais voilà je viens
d'apprendre que david un ami est
gravement malade
david et moi avons le même âge ce n'est
pas le premier de mes amis à être
atteint et là c'en est trop alors je
décide de faire quelque chose
d'important
sans attendre un hypothétique plus tard
quelque chose pour moi je vais faire le
tour du monde
seul un truc un peu fou comme un défi au
delà du même pas
mon objectif est de changer de rythme
d'expérimenter d'autres modes de vie de
sortir de ma bulle mon système de
référence de voir différemment de voir
grand aussi le plus dur c'est de prendre
la décision de partir pas de partir
après c'est facile
nous sommes le 23 février 2014
ça fait quatre mois que je suis parti et
je repense à tous les gens qui avant de
partir m'encourager avec leurs questions
hyper bienveillante
t'as pas peur si tu te fais agresser
non mais tu vas perdre tous ces mois de
salaire d'après quoique en assurance bon
est ce que tu veux vraiment partir là
ses angoisses parle plus d'eux que de
moi et de toute manière les avions
décollent face au vent alors bien sûr
ces questions d'organisation je me
laisse supposer un peu dernière complète
enfin archi dernière minute dans mon cas
alors ça passait deux mais pas rouge
passe à la question fondamentale de
combien de paires de chaussures je
prends mon sac à dos je me suis vraiment
posé la question pour les petits talons
là parce que non mais attends les petits
talons si je suis reçue à l'ambassade
bon ben j'ai bien fait de les prendre
parce que j'ai vraiment passé une soirée
chez un ambassadeur se passe plus de
choses pas prévu quand on fait le tour
du monde
nous sommes le 23 février et je survole
l'atlantique
repenser à un autre grand océan survole
le pacifique parce que je pense à un
autre grand océan l'atlantique
l'huile est pas survolé gelé traversée à
la voile
oui parce que le tour du monde je les ai
commencé par une transatlantique sur un
bateau pour prendre le temps pour tout
couper
y compris la sonnerie du téléphone pour
larguer les amarres dans tous les sens
du terme
ça permet de laisser à terre beaucoup de
choses qui font carrément du bruit alors
j'ai changé j'ai cherché un embarquement
j'ai répondu à une annonce sur internet
et me voilà avec eux deux marins que je
connaissais pas avant de monter à bord
nous sommes trois eh ben ça laisse du
temps seul sur le pont surtout pour les
quarts de nuit qui sont super langues
le temps des beaucoup de question de
temps et le temps quand on voyage c'est
pas le même qu'ici quand on est petit
l'échelle de temps et à une journée puis
après ça passe à la semaine avec les
mercredis et les week end et après les
trimestres
quand on a les bulletins scolaires les
vacances puis on finit par compter en
années et même plus quand les
responsabilités familiales et
professionnelles nous oblige à nous
projeter constamment l'été prochain on
pourrait aller là alors dans deux ans -
change de poste et ma maison j'ai fini
de la payer dans 20 ans moi quand je
voyage mon échelle de temps passez à la
semaine voire à la journée je sais
de quoi les jours suivants seront faits
ça va dépendre de la météo de mon
énergie
et puis surtout surtout des rencontres
au fil de l'eau parce que les rencontres
on en fait plein et dans mon cas il y en
a eu beaucoup qui m'ont fait changer
d'itinéraire et même si j'en avais envie
je pourrais matériellement pas tout
organiser c'est impossible de tout
prévoir
ça peut paraître paradoxal mais c'est
comme si le temps se dilate est alors
que je suis dans un espace de temps très
contraint par exemple une escale la
durée d'un visa et c'est comme ça que
une heure en attendant un train peut
paraître immense riches
il se passe plein de choses c'est là où
profiter du temps présent prend tout son
sens pour moi
les latins parle de iq est donc ici et
maintenant
un jour ou plutôt un matin dans le
désert rouge du wadi rum jordanie le
soleil qui se lève magnifique se fait
piquer la vedette par une petite fourmi
un métier qui transporte une brindille
de dix fois sa taille c'est un trésor
inestimable pour elle parce que une
brindille dans le désert c'est super
rare et elle a dû crapahuter sacrément
loin de sa fourmilière pour la trouver
et en plus elle leur apporte
sûrement pour construire notre
fourmilière agrémenter la sienne je sais
pas et comme cette brindille démesurée
ce bloc dans les aspérités du terrain
elle fait changer la fourmi de direction
aller loin trouver un trésor leur
apporte
et l'incorporer dans sa vie future
infléchir son chemin comme le tour du
monde que je suis en train de vivre
on est tous passés à côté de ces
transports de titan par des fourmis
aussi sauf que là je la regarde vraiment
pour pas oublier l'infiniment petit au
milieu de grands moments exceptionnels
les scientifiques parlent d'espace-temps
les mains pour moi l'espace temps c'est
le temps qui prend toute sa place
quand je voyage - d'ailleurs chacun fait
ce qu'il veut
derrière aller loin c'est la question
que j'ai posée aux gens que j'ai
rencontrés sur la route qu'elle est plus
loin vous êtes allé parce que cette
question je me la pose
c'est quoi le plus loin qu'est ce qui
nous pousse
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve et je me suis
dit qu'en posant cette question à des
gens qui vivaient autrement ça me
parlerait beaucoup de leurs choix de vie
de mes choix de vie c'est des gens que
j'ai rencontrés dans la rue un échange
de sourires
parce qu'il faut que je demande mon
chemin où je comprends jamais rien à la
carte du restaurant parce que je parle
pas toutes les langues du monde ou en
train d'attendre un petit avion qui
n'arrivera jamais dans un aéroport qui
n'a des reports que le nom dans un
désert en amérique latine quand mon vélo
est tombé en rade le sketch j'étais
hyper contente de voir une voiture
arriver et on sait pas quitter pour un
bouton ou dans les bus d'asie du sud-est
sais pas si vous connaissez mal à la
technique de remplissage c'est minimum
trois personnes pour deux sièges
forcément ça incite à leur encontre et
vous venez vous ou encore par hasard sur
le toit d'un immeuble de la vieille
ville de jérusalem
ça a été des rencontres d'une heure de
discussions sur un banc plusieurs jours
pour ceux qui m'ont invité à vivre avec
eux chez eux
qu'importe
le temps à chaque fois ça a été des
rencontres vraiment forte j'ai publié
une centaine de portraits
à travers cette même question que j'ai
posée quelle est plus loin vous étaler
ses pioppo la jeune birmane qui rêve
d'être guide pour touristes
maintenant que le pays est ouvert elle
rêve demande à l'est ayant goon bhagan
elle n'est jamais allée dans ces grandes
villes parce que le plus loin où elle
est allée elle c'est à tanguy pour faire
ses études à 100 km d'ici et pour elle
c'est énorme c'est steve acquis le look
de junkie sur le retour n'aurait pas
donné spontanément envie lui parler si
on n'avait pas était voisin de bus pour
thaïlande alors là je précise pour la
photo il s'est fait super beau et steve
ces trois vies en une
ça commence par le commerce de pierres
précieuses en europe avec la vie sex
drugs and rock'n roll qui va avec et
après ils tombent amoureux alors c'est
la vie rangée au canada et ils montrent
une activité de dépollution pétrolière
et maintenant c'est la protection qui
arriveront en inde et en thaïlande
et quand je lui demande mais qu'il est
le plus - o t elle et il me répond mais
à chaque fois mais je suis allé plus
loin possible et quand on l'écouté on le
croise un problème c'est marc j la
délicieuse margie qui a laissé son fils
en philippines son fils à deux ans et
elle vient travailler à singapour comme
nounou pour gagner de l'argent pour
pouvoir les lever plus tôt le faire
élever alors loin de son fils elle
s'occupe des enfants des autres
c'est in il m'a ou le plus loin où il
est allé c'est au bout de son île là où
il habite depuis l'âge de 15 ans les
mâts ou sont désormais fait mine et qui
sont plutôt bien acceptée en polynésie
sauf par le père de tilly qui est boxeur
tahitien
alors quand il adolescente signifie son
père et haïti pour arriver sur cette île
où je le rencontre forcément le bout de
l'île
ça veut dire beaucoup pour lui c'est
erika sur une autre île de polynésie est
justement cette île à elle me la montre
elles montrent la face cachée celle
qu'on voit pas aux touristes qu'on voit
pas quand on est touriste un truc
vraiment moche
les trucs qui tourne pas rond et
également par mégarde elle me dévoile
des traces de violence conjugale qu'elle
me raconteras j'écris son portrait elle
aussi je demande l'autorisation de le
publier comme je l'aï fait pour les
autres elle me dit oui et puis les je ne
sais pas deux mois plus tard je reçois
un message d'elle elle me dit que les
mots que j'avais écrit lui avait donné
confiance qu'elle voulait pas être la
femme de ce portrait là qu'elle avait
réagi et que son compagnon était
maintenant en prison sans le vouloir
j'avais fait infléchir un petit peu le
chemin de vie de quelqu'un on ne sait
pas la puissance de ce que l'on donne
j'ai beaucoup reçu des autres et je suis
pas sûr qu'ils les tuent je repense à
mon ami david
il est décédé alors qu'il randonnait
dans les amap y en a et je lui ai jamais
dit qu'il avait été le déclencheur de ce
tour du monde et ainsi il me rappelle un
peu tard mais il me le rappelle quand
même pour aujourd'hui qu'on dit jamais
assez aux gens qui comptent pour nous et
des gens qui comptent
on en rencontre autour du monde des gens
à qui on n'a pas le choix que de faire
confiance ou plutôt des gens à qui on
fait le choix de faire confiance je
pense à ceux qui m'ont accueillie chez
eux parce qu'il faut quand même faire
confiance quand on les connaît pas la
veille est allé habiter parfois une
semaine avec eux ou prendre place à bord
d'un avion biplace avec juste un pilote
russo-tchétchène qui m'emmène mais là il
n'y a pas le choix pour faire confiance
j'ai publié ses portraits et d'autres
chroniques sur internet ils en disent
beaucoup sur la vie des autres sur le
regard des autres sur notre perception
et nos propres choix
je voulais pas garder ses histoires pour
moi j'avais envie de les partager et
puis je me suis dit que ça pouvait être
un coup de pouce pour ceux qui hésitent
à partir seul peut-être voyager ça
très facile c'est beaucoup plus facile
qu'on l'imaginé d'abord on n'est jamais
seul je parle pas des autres voyageurs
sac à dos on peut faire un bout de
chemin avec eux sans problème moi j'ai
fait le choix d'être avec les habitants
qui m'ont ouvert leurs portes
voyager en solo c'est pas être seul
c'est être pleinement indépendante est
complètement libre de toute contrainte
à ce moment là il ya un silence
intérieur qui apaise qui ouvre qui
laisse sa place à l'imprévu
ce silence permet de créer les
conditions pour que des choses arrivent
et des choses arrivent
je m'étais dit que en partant au bout du
monde mais au bout en bout bout sans
jamais me retourner à la fois
j'arriverai chez moi j'ai trouvé l'idée
géniale et je m'étais dit ça ça sera mon
plus loin moi j'avais tout prévu sauf
que voyager seul c'est accepter d'avoir
pour compagnon de route l'inattendu
alors oui je suis arrivé au bout oui
j'ai fait le tour du monde oui je suis
arrivée chez moi et et ça avait plus
d'importance c'était plus une question
de distance ou de défi le plus loin où
je suis allé c'est d'avoir voyagé dans
un espace temps différent d'avoir pris
des chemins vers l'imprévisible et
aujourd'hui je continue à le faire
en voyageant et d'une autre manière
aussi au quotidien
chacun sa façon
chacun sa façon de trouver son espace
temps et nourrir son besoin d'
imprévisible
christophe colomb disait on ne va jamais
aussi loin que lorsqu'on ne sait pas où
l'on voit merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]